le marché notre dame est un lieu
incontournable pour la vie de la ville
de versailles
trois matinées par semaine le micro
village de la place du marché s'anime
fruits et légumes en tous genres fromage
viande ou encore plats préparés tout y
est
alors quand on demande aux visiteurs ce
qu'il pense du lieu parce que c'est le
plus beau marché de france bah oui de
dire tu sais ce que c'est versailles ya
du choix même par rapport à la province
je pense que hama rien à envier aux
marchés traditionnels de province les
commerçants l'ambiance
les produits tout est bien il est très
charmant caractéristiques de cette place
13 commis à errer versailles notre dame
est le plus beau marché français le plus
accueillant
construit sous louis xiii le marché est
d'abord un lieu d'histoire
il s'étend dans d'anciennes halles et
sur une place un peu excentré du château
de versailles
les commerçants sont fiers de travailler
sur cet emplacement emblématique
est-ce selon vous le marché pourquoi
cette diversité saluèrent parce qu'on a
à versailles 1 c'est la ville des rois
les votes du concours pour le plus bon
marché de francs seront clôturées le 15
février prochain les 24 marchés encore
en lice auront la chance d'être mise à
l'honneur lors du journal de 13 heures
de jean pierre pernaut avant l'annoncé
officielle du vainqueur